et qui est certaine c'est que le club
méditerranée a tenté depuis pas mal de
temps d'élargir sérieusement le champ
d'activité de ces villages
c'est ainsi que par exemple un des clubs
du sénégal accueille depuis le milieu du
mois de décembre je crois jusqu'au mois
de mai un festival non-stop de jazz et
de musiques traditionnelles africaines
bien l'une de nos équipes est allé voir
ça sur place
cette ambiance il bien celle du club
méditerranée le festival de jazz
organisé par le club qui un temps son
village et descendent dans la rue
africaine
ce retour aux sources mêmes du rythme
c'est sans doute le meilleur exemple de
l'intégration du club dans le pays
et
faux
pour revenir au village l'entrée est
d'abord filtré par les gardiens
sénégalais les almadies ses 17 hectares
d'arbres et de verdure ont été gagnés
sur une lande quasiment désertique à
grand renfort de plantation et
d'arrosage pratiquement cause ici les
membres du club gentil et privilégier
une semaine voyage compris coûtant cette
saison 4630 franc profite au maximum de
la plus grande richesse du pays le
soleil bronzage intégral ou pieds dans
l'eau quand vient le chercher et on
trouve au club
la détente le sport en groupe où chacun
pour soi et je cherchais au club lui
d'abord le repos et puis et puis le soir
il faut dire qu elle m'a dit ce qui est
agréable c'est que il ya une animation
qui est qui est à la fois discrète et
qui permet aux angles des listes de que
je suis de pouvoir
même si l'on ne fait rien on le fait
intensément mais qu'ont certains
cependant il manque quelque chose à
cette ambiance carte postale est un
petit peu pour soit complètement isolée
de
des gens du coin de dakar des relations
africaines
alors pour ceux qui restent au club le
seul contact possible avec la population
africaine en dehors des excursions bien
sûr se fait par l'intermédiaire du
personnel local a découvert aux almadies
le club emploie 170 personnes de dakar
et des engrais pour leur salaire est
fixé par le gouvernement sénégalais 23
mille francs cfa minimum par mois avec
en prime des avantages en nature dans un
pays où le chômage est important ils
sont en quelque sorte des privilégiés
tout comme les membres du club s'occupe
de vous on vous prépare tour vous avez
une paix royale ici et c'est ça l'idéal
pour moi du club m on est au sénégal ici
et ce qu'ils ont profité pour rencontrer
la population
non ce n'est pas mon but moi je viens
ici pour me reposer comme chez lady
profiter du soleil et surtout pour
couper les longs mois d'hiver que nous
avons déjà vu
jusqu'en mai prochain tous les plus
grands noms du jazz mondial vont se
succéder aux m les responsables du club
ont joué la carte culturelle mais la
présence des musiciens fait maintenant
partie du décor
et il semble bien que pour beaucoup il
s'agisse d'un simple divertissement d'un
fond musical
grâce à la musique le club méditerranée
a fait un grand pas vers son intégration
au sénégal reste maintenant à convaincre
les nouveaux arrivants qu'ils peuvent
avoir la possibilité de bronzer tout en
se cultivant c'est ce qu'il souhaite
même pas notre problème notre euro